In cases 4 and 5, your node's parent
is red and its sibling is black.
In both,
you'll need to perform a rotation.
In a rotation, you shift a group of
nodes around in a way that changes
the structure of the tree, but
not the order of the nodes.
Keep in mind that this is still a BST,
so,
we need to keep our
elements in strict order.
In case 4, our red node and
its red parent are not on
the same side of their parents.
Our node is a right child and
its parent is a left child.
Here we will perform a left
rotation since the nodes shift
one place to the left while
maintaining their order.
At this point, we have a set up that
looks exactly like case 5, where
both the red node and its red parent
are on the same side of their parents.
Here, that's the left.
We'll do a right rotation here,
but this time,
involving the grandparent and
both of its children.
We need to swap the colors
of these two nodes as well.
Ta-da!
We have rearranged the nodes without
changing the number of black nodes
in any path.
Those are all of the cases
that could arise in insertion.
Again, we just needed to do some clever
rearranging to keep our red black tree
and BST properties satisfied.
In doing the rotations,
we kept any one sub-tree from
getting much larger than the others.
Insert, like search and delete, is log
of n in the average and worst cases.
BSTs were o of n in the worst case
because they could be unbalanced.
Because we're careful about
staying balanced here,
the run time won't be that large.